put them in threes
makes common sense and then you have to
go now how do i do them in singles
this is a big problem with aikido we
tend to think
singles or sometimes a different
technique than multiples
so we start going knee
i mean we take it on because it's just
the one eye
as soon as we get pressurized we we
actually go
four pieces because we can't work out
what there is
so if you just retreat me
kidneys
[Music]
that makes it real simple doesn't it now
how much you panic which is shown in
in this movement so it's the knee
hey it's the kidneys hey it's the
okay we've got it in the bag i'm sure
i'm hoping you can see that you've got
to start looking at what bits you could
clip out you know
what bits could you clip out
and make it smaller make it shorter
you know by
taking that out to that
to turning
there's a lot to keep looking at but
this is what will make us